okay now i do want to do one more
example with you like i said it's
actually an example
that you already know and i'm going to
see if you guys can do
role marker to grunt work on this one
in advanced there was a topic that you
learned
in term four that had first order
recursive
formulas in it we just didn't call them
that for example
does this ring
any bells what is this which topic is
this from
this is from series and sequences right
because one of the ways you define how
to get to the next term
or get to the nth sum the partial sum is
to look at the gap
from one term previous or one sequence
previous right now if i said i'll just
start with an easy one okay if we did an
arithmetic progression
what was the test for an arithmetic
progression how do you know
that something is arithmetic yeah
there's a common difference if you look
at
two terms that are adjacent consecutive
and then you look at another two terms
then the difference between them should
be the same
okay another way of saying that is if
you look at the difference between
two partial sums a complete one and then
one before that right the difference
will be just that one
nth term which we have um a formula for
that don't we
it's n sorry it's a actually
a plus some number of that common
difference you're telling me about right
how many common differences are there
and
minus 1 because you start here and then
you add one for every other term
okay so this formula here right
this is a first order recursive formula
do you agree
but we have a non-recursive formula to
help us work out
the same thing if you want say
the nth partial sum you don't need to
rely on working out all of the sums
before that
you can go directly there we have this
trick with arithmetic progressions if
you remember
we had to um pair up every term the
first and the last one because they're
small and big and then the next one in
and the next one in so you actually get
once you pair up all the terms that's
how many pairs you've got
you have 2a right there's the first term
which is a
and then the last term which also has a
in it plus what
it's the same thing again isn't it it's
it's that number of common differences
so i just want you to look at these two
things right it's very similar
to our setup here you've got a recursive
formula
this is just part of the definition of
an arithmetic progression
and then you've got this thing now i
told you there was this way that you
could sort of
like logically like diagrammatically
work it out first and last
second and second last and so on right
but we can prove this by induction and
induction is the perfect object to use
because it deals with objects in the
ones just previous
or objects and the ones just next so i'm
just going to put
these here for you take this recursive
formula
as your foundation just like we did in
example one
see if you can prove this i already know
that you know it's true
okay but can you prove that this form
this non-recursive formula
is true by induction
all right everyone i'm going to going to
help you out um i saw some people who
are very very close so i think now is an
appropriate my
moment to uh show you how this works
before i get dived into that i want to
just address a really good question
morgan asked which is around this
um i have i have trained you well
if you look at this question and you're
like oh there's a domain restriction
on the values of n um i better use that
right when you were doing for example
inequality
proofs um especially induction
inequality proofs
if you never referred to this you are in
some serious trouble right because
you're like
you can't prove the result works because
for previous terms it shouldn't work
right
now if you went through this proof
successfully you might have thought
uh did i ever use it like i assumed this
of k
did i ever have to say something about k
being greater than or equal to two
and the answer is probably not and i'll
tell you why
why is it that for example if i gave you
some
inequality like this
right this one here okay hopefully you
know enough about this
graph and this graph
to know that sometimes this is not true
do you agree
it's um if you think back to the
beginning of this topic statements are
either
true or false or there could be
conditional as in this case right
now if you don't invoke the condition on
that you're in trouble
that's why we put a condition like n is
greater than whatever it happens to be
but this condition is here for a rather
different reason it's not because this
formula
isn't true it's because this formula
doesn't really
have a sensible definition think about
this what if i tried and said hey what
about
n equals 0 right on this thing right
what would that even mean what what does
sn represent the sum
of the first n terms right
so if i said to you oh okay take the sum
of the zeroth term and the sum of the
negative ones like what what is this
even
for our series and sequences right the
whole point is we start somewhere to
find and then we keep on going
we progress right that's what we deal
with in the world of arithmetic
progressions
so in this case the whole idea of an ap
is not defined for n is less than this
particular value
so really it's more of a formality than
in this case where it just
mathematically breaks you if you don't
pick the right values of n
does that answer your question as to why
it's there and you don't explicitly
refer to it
all right i've already begun this proof
by induction as you can see and maybe
you're like yep that part i got
the test case here it's actually a
little more work than you are used to
because
you have to deal with the fact that some
of these pronumerals
are constants they never go away like
i'm proving this true for any a
any first term for any d any common
difference right
so unlike normal proofs by induction
where i rubbed it off
whereas oh i just end up with 5 that's
my answer and that was what i wanted
here
you have to end up with algebra on both
sides it may have taken a second to
tweak for you
that when you go to the recursive
formula you write it down
for the first value it's supposed to
work at n equals 2
and then you're like now what
right you actually have to deal with the
fact that by definition we define
the sum of the first one terms as the
first term which is a is that okay
and then your algebra kind of sorts you
out from there so there's my test
there's my assumption
what does my proof step look like i've
already done the left hand side for you
what does the right hand side look like
come on help me out you should be able
to write this even without doing much to
it right
uh who's someone who hasn't said
anything aaron do you have a
do you have a first line here for the k
plus step
k plus one case rather yeah i'll give
you a clue it starts with a k
yes very good so remember we're
substituting k plus one into
n right over two and then what
fantastic thank you very much aaron now
that kd of course it comes from
uh sorry i'm thinking of first person
shooters when i see k d
there's not a kd ratio guys um i'm
putting k plus one into here the minus
one cancels
and then the common difference is on
along the end okay so this is what i'm
trying
to prove now to make it easier for me
and you saw me do this in the previous
proof and sometimes
um it's just useful improved by
induction right i'm going to go from
this step
and i'm actually going to expand it just
a little bit because it's going to be
easier for me to
arrive at an expanded form there will be
less thinking for me to do so when you
expand
this i'm actually going to put that half
out the front that doesn't change things
very much
i'm going to do k plus 1 times this
binomial
okay i think correct me from wrong
because i've already made one mistake
today
i'm going to get 2 a k k squared d
there's me distributing the k and then
i'm going to get 2 a
plus k d that's me distributing the 1.
is that ok checks out all right
wonderful so here comes the actual proof
now i know where i'm going and i saw
some of you didn't write
this where i'm going step and that's
really important okay
now i'm going to give it a go i can't
use this as my foundation
what do i know what's established that i
can start from
from the recursive formula uh this one
right here
i'm gonna try out the recursive formula
for k plus one
yeah so here we go uh from recursive
formula
in these kinds of questions where you
have two competing formulas
one and two to talk about the same kinds
of objects i think it is a very very
helpful thing to always specify where
you're getting your thing from
uh what have we got i'm going to go over
this way if i try out
n equals k plus 1 i'll get s
ok plus 1 minus what
s of k that's me substituting k plus 1
in here plus 1 minus 1 cancels
bam of course that's going to be useful
because how are you going to use this in
a second on the next line
i will substitute in the assumption
right here i'm not quite there yet but
that's where i'm going
and then i'm going to put k plus 1 into
here what do you get
a plus what k d it was that same thing
that happened up here wasn't it a plus k
d all right let's use our assumption now
so i've got
s of k plus 1 hanging out the front and
then
this whole thing all right let's write
it k on
2 outside of 2 a plus
k minus 1 d equals
by assumption
how's it looking to you so far really
just done a substitution okay
now really all the work that remains is
just some careful and methodical
algebra this is what i'm going to make
the subject because that's where i'm
headed right
so i'll make that on the left hand side
i will add this somewhat awful looking
mess
to the right hand side and hopefully i
arrive
here could you raise your hand if you
got there hands up i see one two
okay wonderful all right what i'm going
to do is i will finish writing that up
there for those of you who didn't raise
your hand but for those of you who did
well done that wasn't so hard was it the
logic is
the same kind of thing we've been
employing improve my mathematical
induction this whole time
you